I am a disorganized mess today hope
you're all doing well yeah that's a
little better I'm okay
like for the record just yeah feeling I
had like a really productive week or two
but things have feel like feeling much
less organized in with it so far this
week and I'm starting to get annoyed
with myself for that no pretense this
time that's not water obviously this is
it's apple cider it is hot apple cider
because it's fall haha I I do love the
flavors of fall and yes that includes
pumpkin spice I don't have an issue with
it I think it's good overused but it's
good alright ah looks like some people
are getting an error message so can
somebody let them know in the chat just
hit the refresh that should clear it up
I actually had it too huh so yeah don't
know why I did that
I hate autumn because the daylight hours
were too short but I also ate summer
because the daylight hours are too long
yeah I think autumn is the perfect blend
when we get into winter
yes daylight hours Oh daylight hours are
too short because when we are in the
middle of winter where I live when I go
to work in the morning
it is dark I want to go home from work
in the evening it is dark that is
depressing
uh Hufflepuff from Scotland oh it's late
over there and good evening to you as
well Castillo
ravenclaw from California just got here
what's happening not much ma'am we just
started my main issue with pumpkin spice
is that the is that the pacing isn't
very good not entirely even sure what
you mean by that but okay
apologies for teasing you I when like I
tease myself I lose track of stuff so
don't don't even sweat it
Oh duh birthday girls here welcome ah
hufflepuff puck widget and puck I'm
sorry puck wuji from Maryland ah
I tried pumpkin spice once and threw it
and I threw up afterwards ah you know
what was interesting couple um a couple
weekends ago I guess it would have been
almost a month now listen I went to a
woodchuck cidery near Middlebury in
Vermont woodchuck does great stuff and
they had yeah and they give what you can
get when you go to a lot of cider ease
or breweries or what have you get sort
of a sampler of the various things and
they had they had a putt that uh a hard
pumpkin thing what was interesting about
that is because my brain had
automatically assumed pumpkin spice but
it wasn't I tried it it was just like
pumpkin
it wasn't bad it just threw me off
because I've been so used to pumpkin
spice being the thing so that that was
those an interesting thing it was a bad
joke but thanks jerilyn for appreciating
appreciating it yeah she's good for that
and she she's often like quicker on the
draw than I am so there's a pretty good
chance if I didn't get it she probably
did
ah just coming from watching some Buffy
oh where yeah in that pumpkin spice is
overrated overexposed overexposed I'll
give you I still like it feel like
pumpkin spices is an American thing
because I've never seen it here yeah I
mean it's pretty it's pretty widespread
in the States
I mean honestly we can partly blame you
know between Dunkin Donuts and Starbucks
for that because those two places are so
prolific once they started doing it it
really felt like it was everywhere so
apple cider is better than pumpkin spice
well yeah clearly did you hear about the
Netflix Paul Rudd thing um I mean I saw
a trailer for a thing is there more to
it than just the trailer can you give a
sneak peak of your review of time of
angels flesh and stone' the sneak peak
is that that that two-parter frustrates
me it's got some really good stuff in it
but it frustrates me how from Canada I
love the dark like it sorry Dark Crystal
Netflix show was an amazing tribute to
Jim Henson I loved the voice working the
puppetry dete is awesome deep is great I
I think I like hop a little bit more
than deep but he's definitely the best
gelfling my new meds say no alcohol oh
that I mean you know you you you work
with what you've got and you do what you
gotta do but that does suck that kind of
thing happens just learn that you're in
Vermont I live there as a kids a great
place to grow up it is I did grow up
here I also want I always want to
clarify I want to say that it's not like
I never love for Maude it's not like I
grew up here and I'm still here I've
never been anywhere no I left I lived in
Boston I lived in New York I've traveled
around but I came back I like it here
pumpkin spice cereal and sausage okay
yeah nobody needs that like I like
pumpkin spice but there are some things
it does not belong in
two questions one weird one request um
okay just just drink water instead
thanks everyone for the birthday wishes
yeah absolutely Donna it's great to have
you I'm I'm honored that you decided to
spend part of your birthday here what
the heck is pumpkin spice it's it's an
overused autumn flavor shows you have a
nostalgia for I mean the one that I
happen to salad for that is held up the
best is the Real Ghostbusters card to
them probably most other stuff from my
childhood that I've gone back and
revisited hasn't held up very well
crater of Gotham is making a prequel
show called pennyworth about Alfred's
adventures when he was younger
pennyworth it I know about pennyworth
it's not I didn't I'm pretty sure it's
not the same people who are behind
Gotham and I'm pretty sure it's
unconnected um I haven't looked into it
because I just I don't I didn't it
didn't look that interesting to me I'm
pretty sure it's not related though
where did you get your shirt well this
shirt well actually first of all Thank
You Tyler awesome super appreciate it
this shirt is this is me being a shill
this is my own merch so if you actually
check the description for the tee public
you will find this available in a wide
variety of colors and multiple flesh
tones so try to be as inclusive as I
could be with the design of this shirt
so I got it from myself well a theme has
it evolved despite a lack of one and its
pumpkin spice yes this has become the
pumpkin spice live stream oh well so
apparently Tony starts gonna be in the
Black Widow movie well I'd heard it was
a prequel so I mean that I can live with
that
Primrose Hill and Bruno Heller are
making penne with okay so I guess Bruno
Heller was involved in Gotham okay huh
showing of the doll
yeah I'll take it after watching some
Torchwood with her my friend that I have
decided to watch children of Earth yes I
have warned her like just just be sure
you are prepared to be a shoulder for
her to cling to for whatever support she
needs after watching that thing just be
sure you're gonna be that alright when
you need a support network to watch
children of Earth for real let's see
pumpkin spice of the Dalek someone had
to suppose they did I grew up with
Cheers Carla was my favorite as a kid I
liked Carla when I was younger Tuesday I
cheers is one of those shows that I grew
up with the kind of didn't what's your
comfort show the one you put on when you
need a fix for a mad day um
I mean there are some episodes of Doctor
Who that I'll turn to like specific sort
of upbeat ones that's but coming back to
cheers there's like a collection of
shows I used to spend the summers with
my grandparents because I went to day
camp you know where they lived and you
know so I was with them on the weekends
in the and in the evenings and there
were a bunch of shows that I haven't
awareness up but very rarely actually
sit down to watch and I think of them as
my grandfather's shows and Cheers was
one Seinfeld was another friend's mash a
lot of stuff like that
he was also how I got into Star Trek The
Next Generation because he liked that
quite a bit which was almost kind of an
anomaly for him but he did enjoy that
show and I used to watch that with him
too but the funny thing is Cheers
I think I've only seen about maybe three
episodes front to back start to finish
of Cheers but it's a fantastic show and
I really like it and I like it's again
it's on the list of things up if I had
free time I totally sit down and watch
through it it's on Netflix but
I don't are you afraid of the dark
excuse me are you afraid of the dark
will always be my favorite childhood
show I think I know I think Italy ever
watch part of that once hmm
I'm more into Frasier I'm fair I never
really watched Frasier
um too much but it seemed decent for
what it was
I always watch the Golden Girls with my
grandparents but my my my daughter's
mother is one of the biggest Golden
Girls fans I will ever know change oh
she got me a mug and Golden Girls fans
will get this she got me a mug that says
you're the stand to my Dorothy and
here's the best part she got that for me
after we got divorced my friend was okay
so this is Torchwood again my friend was
already upset after the season two
finale I described the children of Earth
as the finality but Owen and Tasha's
deaths replaced with Abby's mom times
twenty uh my dad fixed Eve miles his
roof and never stops talking about it
hey you know what when you have your
brushes with the fame you hold on to
those stories gay hearts Thank You Jamie
very much I'm weird my favorite show as
a kid was a 70s show called emergency
I'm not sure you even heard of that one
the dune spices really pumpkin spice the
spice must flow Madiba
my grandmother introduced me into Fawlty
Towers what was fun with my grandmother
is I I got my grandmother into Nintendo
I I feel like I may have mentioned this
at some points previously but my
maternal grandparents love mash but my
great-uncle hated it he was a medic in
the green war and said it wasn't like
that yeah that can happen but my
grandmother originally got a Nintendo
because of the summers that I would
spend down there so that you know I
would have it for the weekends or you
know so I wouldn't get too bored during
periods where you know the weather was
good or what have you and she started to
play it on her own and my grandmother
got into puzzle games and Mario
specifically but platformers she liked
Tetris she liked dr. Mario
she it was a period she was better than
I was I remember calling her up stairs
for her to beat some of the Super Mario
3 bosses for me
my grandmother had to be Roy Koopa for
me that guy used to give me trouble ah
Nintendo grandma yeah you know it was
great the only reason she stopped gaming
was her reaction time slowed down too
much she bailed on 3ds she didn't like
the n64 she didn't like the 3d thing at
all but then Nintendo had the Gameboy
Advance and the DS and she would play 2d
Mario's on that like I said up until her
her refix
her reflexes slowed to where it just
didn't work anymore I got soap operas
from my grandmother and mom they are way
too predictable thankfully soap operas
never seem to be part of any of my
family's TV Guide so I never even got
that stuff by proxy is that t-shirt your
design yes it is I mean I didn't like
draw it and it's my concept and I
approved it I commissioned somebody else
to do the actual art cuz I can't draw
but yes this is this is my design this
is my t-shirt available on my merch
store down in the description I'm a
shill
your grandma sounds way cooler than mine
my grandmother was she was a saint you
the other thing that she did that was
amazing to me still is Gotham is a soap
opera isn't it it kinda is and honestly
this is something Liz will point out
superhero comics are soap operas for
teenage boys but anyway the other thing
that my grandmother would do so growing
up I didn't have TV in the house
like we had television sets like I had a
Nintendo Wii had VHS and we would rent
movies and all that stuff but we didn't
have a television signal we didn't have
the rabbit ears nothing was coming in so
I didn't watch TV growing up but I still
had a few TV shows that I liked cuz like
I said there were times that I would go
down to my grandmother's and she knew
what I liked so my grandmother used to
tape my favorite cartoons on to VHS
tapes off the TV and send them to me so
I think I've still got some of the Attic
I have boxes and boxes of he-man and
Thundercats and ghostbusters and even
some stuff like Sesame Street on these
VHS tapes and here's the kicker though
she edited out the commercials and the
only way for her to do that was to sit
there and watch it while it entered
stopped the recording during the
commercials and then bring it back after
the commercial was done oh she was a
saint where did you get your 10th doctor
coat I can't find a decent replica but
yours looks good that one was actually
sent to me by a by a fan that was sent
to me I guess around I guess was around
Christmas or leading up to it that got
sent to me I think it came from Amazon I
don't know for certain though that is an
incredible grandmother mine put up with
my obsession with Shira yeah great
grandparents are amazing
cool grandmothers are awesome Blackadder
goes forth was good not hugely into the
other ones I've only seen a bit some
pieces of Black Adder
I've seen like The Blackout or Christmas
special like four times and only bits
and pieces of anything else can't buy a
t-shirt but can do this oh thank you
Amanda I appreciate that greatly you're
on my TV ooh
do not attempt to adjust the signal
there is nothing wrong with your
television set which is a weird thing
for me to reference because before my
time and somebody I've never seen mash
was basically a war drama disguised as a
sitcom they even removed the laugh track
in the in his final season yeah it moved
away from the jokes the longer it went
on the only thing my grandmother did
that was great was giving me a 6 CD set
of opera music we didn't get along well
politically but always be grateful for
that well I'm glad you can at least have
that it's tough um you know when you
have we don't line up with your family
because um I honestly there's massive
swaths of my family of my local family
like aunts and uncles and cousins why
not who I have zero in common with both
in terms of general interests and
definitely in terms of political
leanings and it makes things awkward
sometimes I mean I don't we don't get
into fights with this just whatever we
round them there's so much silence cuz
like there's nothing for us to talk
about and anything that we might talk
about has the potential spark an
argument my my aunt and uncle actually
just just left from having visited for
the weekend and I think my uncle looked
me in the eye once in the four days he
was around yeah
I like the original Outer Limits but my
heart belongs to the Twilight Zone see
the thing is Caroline I've seen actually
very little of any of them I've seen a
couple of episodes of my think one of
the revivals about our limits cuz hasn't
it been revived like two or three times
and I've seen some of the original
Twilight Zone which holds up
surprisingly well I think it's just
because the core concepts were so solid
if you owned a meeseeks box what would
you do with the meeseeks I I don't know
what these words mean I just don't know
my grandma watched Doctor Who with me
took me to the train station looked
after me and my and I was younger from
time to time and talked to me and took
an interest in me she was the best I'll
miss her yeah I mean when you when you
have that kind of connection with with a
relative you know when they are gone
that's that's rough I mean my
grandparents passed away guess about
four years ago now god it might even be
five yeah I think it was five years ago
now it's been a little while and I still
miss them and I always miss them both of
them because as much as I don't get
along with us you know a lot of my
immediate family around where I live I
don't I always got along with my
grandparents they were amazing people
I still remember getting angry at my
grandma when I was four or because she
color Mike Thomas the Tank Engine wrong
oh the things we get hung up on he seeks
our from Rick and Morty ah well see
that's why I wouldn't know it
I don't watch freakin Morty I watched
three episodes and realize I don't like
these people I don't want to spend any
more time with them and I haven't gone
back like I get what I'm not saying it's
a bad show I saw enough of it to
understand why it's smart and clever and
people
like it but I'm just like I don't want
to be around these characters what
colors would you'd like to see on the
Daleks if they get a redesign and do you
think they need one I mean no they don't
need what I actually kind of liked what
was starting to happen the tenon Linda
Moffitt Sarah which was they stopped
having as clear a delineation between
the different looks of the dogs and just
started throwing them up there I mean it
didn't always work perfectly because you
know it did throw me off when like some
70s Daleks showed up at the start of
Magician's apprentice but I kind of
liked that there was just a mix of them
I kind of liked that I think that's a
way to also Loki introduced some new
designs and alterations without having
to do something like the new paradigm
Daleks where you do the whole thing from
scratch and like relaunch the entire
thing just introduced just put them in
the mix how would you read is I don't
know another designer will you wear a
war doctor costume for the 50th
anniversary special that is a very cool
idea and no I won't because I do not
have the disposable funds to shell out
for an entire costume for literally one
review that is a cool idea though it
becomes one of those things that makes
me wish I could afford to do that Abbey
Road by the Beatles turns 50 today are
fifty soon sorry and also Thank You
Connor thank you very much um they need
to bring back the renegade Imperial dog
Civil War oh yeah oh yeah I totally
agree they need to have more in fights
between the dogs of the Beatles every
road is not one of the ones I know that
one there's actually only a couple of
Beatles albums I'm like I know a lot of
Beatles songs but there's only a couple
of albums that I know really well I know
Sergeant Pepper really well
I know let it be pretty well but I've
said this before I'm more wood for that
era I'm more of a stones person than a
Beatles person mail like The Beatles but
I forgot this year my fear
Albus Potter goes to Hogwarts for the
first time that wonderful tradition of
starting to overrun things that were
technically pieces of fiction that were
technically set in the future yeah
that's that's always uh that's always
kind of a fun thing have you watched the
movie adaptation of clue oh my god I
love clue I grew up on clue
I love the heck out of that movie so so
much the first thing I ever saw it's in
Korean so later on seeing him in Rocky
or having clue in him being you know
stuck-up Butler as a point of reference
that was interesting that's a great
movie I loved it
I remember yellowy yelling Thomas isn't
yellow he's not a PE I mean you wouldn't
have been wrong but again the things
that bug us when we're young what is
your favorite celebrity experience at a
con mine would be a tie between Matt
Smith Capaldi William Daniels or John
Barrowman well I I've really effectively
only ever met two celebrities at econo
I've met Tim Curry and I've met John
Barrowman and between the two it is
gonna be Tim Curry meeting John
Barrowman was wonderful and he was an
absolute delight but meeting Tim Curry
was a borderline profound experience
that like I hadn't expected that to
impact me the way that it did and so
that's that's hard to top that one I
hate him so much that the flames flames
on the side of my face just re-watched
parting of the ways it seemed to
foreshadow Jack's torch WA Brewers onna
first time he's in charge he's
immediately harsh or more impatient and
willing to let people die I mean I
complain and Torchwood that I don't find
Jack as fun there and I like his more
swashbuckling attitude just have on
Doctor Who but what they presented in
Torchwood it wasn't like it came out of
nowhere it wasn't ever that I didn't buy
it I just didn't enjoy it as much
which which is so often like I feel like
some it's a drum I keep beating when
people like try it try and explain
things that I have issues with but in
the comment sections after reviews you
know they're always like oh well it's
like this because of this light no no no
my issue is not that it's narrative ly
justified it's that I don't like it
understanding the narrative reason for
it doesn't suddenly mean I enjoy it
making sense doesn't automatically make
something work for me it helps but
that's not the only bar something has to
clear so that drives me nuts
did you like Peter Capaldi's arctor yeah
told us my favorite doctor right now and
like I say right now very specifically
because my favorite doctor has changed
in the past and is liable to change
again in the future but for right now
yeah he's my favorite did you prefer a
spiral the dragon or Crash Bandicoot
I only ever played either of them
sporadically so I do not feel qualified
to answer that question did you hear
about Eccleston's battle with a anorexia
T and depression I always loved him but
respect him even more for pushing
through and still giving us a great
doctor performance I actually did hear
about that and actually it it brings
another layer to his his reluctance to
be involved in Doctor Who related things
since having left coz we've always kind
of known I'm not a lot of the details
but we've always kind of known broadly
speaking that he left the show on bad
terms with with some of the people
behind it and with BBC as an entity but
it is interesting to realize that
there's also a certain amount of
personal baggage for him as well because
he made it at a point in his life when
he was sick and ill and dealing with a
lot of issues both physical and
mental health issues and it brings
another layer to his reluctance to get
involved in Doctor Who again beyond you
know very sporadic little things usually
has as little tributes for for fans you
know directly to fans or whatnot because
it takes him back to a time that he
probably for the sake of his own health
needs to move on from and I've never
been one to really hold Eccleston's feet
to the fire I've I've known some fans
who have and actually one who I need to
see if he is aware of that cuz I'm kind
of hoping he'll ease off it's a friend
of mine but I'm like dude so especially
realizing that it's it just it brings a
lot more to the table as to you know the
guys reasons I did drawings for Matt
Capaldi Matt said these are really good
keep drawing buddy I also gave compiled
me a Doctor Who story I wrote he loved
them both he also drew a Dalek on it oh
that's awesome John very nice I heard
that I take it you heard any money any
money passed away I did excuse me
the the way I heard mmm the way I heard
was more bit do you like I've mentioned
this here before but it's probably been
a while I found out Eddie Money died
because of the Google cool like quick
poll have I talked about the Ghul pool
before to folks even know what I mean
when I say that or should I explain that
I met Matt Smith and Robert Englund at a
con on my 24th birthday oh that's very
cool if I could think of a terrible
Christmas movies Kirk Cameron saving
Christmas I have no interest in watching
that no idea I don't please explain
explain explain okay explain explain
okay so the cool pool this one I'm gonna
emphasize this because some people find
it in a really
bad taste so that's that's my my
heads-up I didn't invent this I do
however participate in it so I have
friends near where I live who run a kind
of betting pool around what celebrities
are gonna die in the next calendar year
there's a bunch of us there's like 20
people in on this thing and we have a
draft every year where you pick 75 and
we have to go round-robin because
obviously there are there are prime
choices where you draft what famous
people you think are going to die and
somebody had and every time it does the
guy who runs the ghoul pool sends out an
email to everyone who's in it saying hey
this person died this participant in the
ghoul pool had them and so here are the
current scores for the year I never win
but it's it's really bad and it's also
designed in a way that you can't just
you can't just load up on like really
old celebrities because of the older
somebody is the fewer points they're
worth you can draft anyone up to a
hundred up to 99 years old cuz once they
had a hundred they're not worth anything
so from ninety to a hundred if they pass
away they're ten points eighty to ninety
is twenty 70 to 80 is thirty etcetera
etc etc so if you can peg someone who's
gonna bite it young that's a lot of
points
Oh God we are all going to hell we are
all very very sick people participating
in this but I it's it's sick but I do
enjoy it
are there prizes for yeah there's a cash
prize it's it you you haven't you buy
into this thing who won in 2016 i I mean
I'm not gonna name names for the other
players not me
don't lie you guys dress
as the absorber hop in the Patang and do
magical ritual and caused the
celebrities to die I don't dress up as
the absorber for the pétain no comment
on the ceremonies in your opinion what
makes a good public service announcement
I don't know if I ever see one I'll tell
you do you have any pets do you consider
yourself a dog person or a cat person I
like both but if you're gonna make me
pick one um it's gonna be dogs I like
cats the cats are jerks they're very
cute jerks for they're jerks I go
personally currently have any pets my
kid has a hamster I totally get what you
mean about getting it but not liking it
with things like Jack sorry if I came
across as a you don't you just don't get
a commenter I'm so yeah I kind of
overreacted to that baby he just got a
hit a nerve and then I responded sort of
with the weight of when that sort of
thing happens you'd actually didn't come
off that bad I think I might have
overdone it
just watch pyramids of Mars awesome I've
got a review up so go check that out if
you dress up as a Patang how do you deal
with the height issues well that's the
beauty of cosplay my good sir
you you get to be interpretive or my
good my good rodent sorry I'll try I try
my best but you know that cosplay does
not have to be exact you get to be
representative and just bring about the
soul of the character so as long as you
run around snarling at people and just
stuffing stuffing in your face yeah you
know you're pretty much the tank
[Laughter]
thanks John
thanks so much for that if you came upon
a roundabout would you steal it if no
one would ever know very confused by
that cuz right I don't know if it had
day if it has a different meaning
elsewhere but around about here is is in
traffic it's not something you can steal
I'm very confused
also dogs stink so two counts
differently in distinctly different ways
but come on have you ever listened to
the song the bad touch by the bloodhound
game yeah I was in college when that
came out yeah I've heard it favorite
candy Oh like it's a super mood
dependent I can kind of go all over the
place but like some go to some good go
to things are things like spree
preferably the hard one I don't like the
chewy spree as much skittles are always
good you're really on the ball Carolyn
with dealing with the trolls so props to
you you you've been doing really well
with that there's a misconception that
the third doctor was the only one who
got in physical contact many classic
doctors got physical
when necessary William Hartnell and
Tommy Baker um it is a misconception
that he's the only one I do think it is
safe to say he was the one who did it
most readily like it was a regular part
of his repertoire as opposed to
something done when necessary will you
ever do a review of Clue I'm not
shouting all right I am I'm shouting I'm
showing up uh I don't know that's one of
those things where like I haven't
thought of why it's awesome in a long
time so like maybe if I if I got back
into those I would but that's one of
those things like it's hard to find a
space for it because you know I I'm I've
got a lot of stuff going right now I
mean I'd be happy to talk about I love
that movie but it's that's also one that
recently um pushing up roses did a video
on it earlier this year that was
phenomenal and met so that also be a lot
of those issues of do I have more to
bring to this conversation thoughts on
oh hang on lost it yeah thoughts on the
first doctor people call him moody which
he is sometimes but that isn't the
defining character trait I see him as
protective and tough guy with the
twinkle in his eye um I mean like I do
think especially depending on how early
in his run you are Moody is not unfair
especially early on I mean I'm like I've
warmed to them a bit over time versus
you know my first impressions of him but
he's still on the lower end for me all
things considered thoughts on
creepypasta I mean it's that kind of
stuff is vaguely interesting it's not
something I'm very big into hello from
Wales awesome Howard the Duck is the
best film ever made
disgust um I be careful where you say
that that's that's how you get sectioned
randomise clue or all endings cool Oh
all endings you gotta have all endings
this is an incomplete experience
otherwise I don't love Ainsley as the
master but for different reasons than
most he just seemed like diet oh god oh
he doesn't bring something more
the table um yeah
yeah I mean Anthony as the master was I
mean he just really really leaned into
the cam piest elements of Doctor Who of
the time I think his best performances
in the part world early on although to
be fair I've also heard he's very good
in survival which i Selvan got into and
I need to but every time I've seen him
show up after Castro called up
he's been kind of painful and I even
kind of have the issues with this
performance and Logopolis from being
perfectly honest you're prisoner of
azkaban revisit was great I agree with
your points it is my favorite as it is
the first Harry Potter film I saw in
nineteen it made me read the boss that's
awesome it's still a very good movie but
like I see the level of praise it gets
and I'm like but do you have a go-to
classic Who episode yeah city of death
that's that's that's an easy call for me
which clue ending is your favorite I
mean the real one all endings that's a
good answer to American Beauty turns 20
next month yeah somebody my god somebody
else mentioned that to me and I can't
huh might have been on Twitter thing was
on - yeah it was on Twitter because I
alluded to having watched something that
I forgot how pretentious it was and
somebody asked if it was American Beauty
to which I said no I I don't I got rid
of my copy for American Beauty for
reasons I hope I don't have to explain I
didn't like that movie though I haven't
I didn't read what I mean I'm not on
prep I'm I never we watch it again now
but um you know I didn't like it for a
while so my memories of it are solid if
you were to cast a new version of
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy who
would you cast
see I don't think I'd have it in my
heart to even run that exercise because
I talked about this when I when I talked
about my love of of Hitchhiker's Guide I
just don't think it works as well in a
visual medium it works pretty well in
audio format I think it works best on
the page I just think you lose so much
doing the doing it visually with that
with those stories that I just I don't
know I can't even I can't even bring
myself to to fantasize about it because
I'm just like yeah but this is a bad
idea like my ability to do hypotheticals
is limited in that way because if the
premise of the hypothetical is something
that I wouldn't actually want to happen
I have a hard time forcing my brain to
start thinking of possibilities I might
be related to John bear John Barrowman
down the lines how would you end up
being really to do them down the line as
opposed to right now or like you might
find out I'm I don't know I don't know
things if folks hadn't guessed I have
seen survival I really liked him there
cuz they finally did something new and
interesting with his version I won't
tell you what it was done no spoilers
much appreciated I was gutted by Spacey
as he was with one of my favorite actors
yeah
things really started to to come out you
know in the last few years
Spacey was one of the ones that really
hurt for me to find out because he keep
probably was one of my favorite working
actors and not that it was any less
horrific what anyone else did but
there's just something about when you
feel like you like there's a massive
stain put on something you used to love
it just sucks it's also part of maturing
and just coming to terms with
reality so it's not something like oh
I'm so mad that this stuff came out
because they can't enjoy these these
movies anymore I'm not happy about that
but like stuff needed to come out and
need to stop so if I'm no longer able to
watch American Beauty or the ref or the
usual suspects with a clear conscience
that is way less important than putting
a stop to what was going on so you know
you digest how many Ravenclaw's do you
know I want to select few I know New
Hampshire but I'm curious about Vermont
um well I mean Liz is a ravenclaw that's
my partner um other than that I don't
know too many off the time I have that I
know for sure like Liz and I when we're
bored well sometimes start sorting
things into hogwards which we've
actually like done here we did it with
uh with Marvel phase one characters and
like we've done it with she or our
characters and Buffy characters and
we've done it with our friends we've
sorted our friends into Hogwarts houses
but that's us guessing I don't know how
many of them actually are what we think
they are so when did you meet Tim Curry
I met Tim Curry at Boston fan Expo in
[Music]
1/t I maybe it was last year ya know ah
see the last year the year before it was
either 2018 or 2017 ah I can't remember
now which is your favorite Dirk Gently
book um I think I like holistic
detective agency a little bit better
than long dark teatime of the soul
I saw your Marvel Hogwarts video good
stuff Thanks
we are eventually going to continue that
we will eventually do phase two one of
these days wrangling schedules like even
with my partner because like there's
plenty of time that we spend together
but we're not always here where I
and she's not always up for taking an
hour to sit down and talk about this
stuff so you know which is fine I
wouldn't expect her to be able to do
want to do that at the drop of a hat so
you know you'd think oh we'll just do
that look we try and actually have a
life outside of my shooting videos and
recording podcasts so you know I work to
her schedule she doesn't work to mine we
need another sorting video with you -
those are my favorite I mean I
definitely want to do it I met Matt
Smith and John Barrowman in Boston 2017
Tim Curry was there so probably 2017
yeah yeah that lines up that makes sense
cuz you do Hogwart houses for Dark
Crystal character or Gotham characters
um Wow I mean God 90% of Gotham's just
gonna be slower and probably big part of
why I like the show so much um like it's
tough was something like doing it for
Dark Crystal I would want to but the the
viewership on the Dark Crystal review
was not that high which would make me
hesitant to dedicate another video to
something as ancillary as that and again
it it bums me out sometimes when I have
to own up to how much the viewcount kind
of determines what I do but I'd be very
insincere if I pretended otherwise I
mean it's also part of why like I'm
gonna finish up the let's play that I've
been doing I don't know what I'm gonna
new another one because you know the
views have gone down every single video
and I'll finish it out cuz I'm pretty
sure I'm almost done the game um just so
that you know I have the complete thing
up but you know that there are there are
just things that I would like to do that
there doesn't seem to be as much
interest in as I would care for did you
watch the new Joker movie if so no
spoilers please it's not out yet is it
did do you folks think I get to pre
screenings
I'm not an actual critic you know that
right have you seen the video where Matt
Smith is on stage sees a kid dressed up
as a doll like and he picks her up and
they talk she says exterminate and
everything is so cute I have not seen
that one can't wait for the rest of your
11th doctor reviews favorite doctor and
no Joker isn't out yet okay I didn't
think it was mmm it was at a film
festival yeah I love Vermont it wasn't
out of Film Festival anywhere near me
I'm gonna pop on over to the discord
even though there wasn't a a theme I
just gotta see if there are any
questions that popped up over there so
give me just a moment um here's a
question brought on by what I'm
currently hearing how early is too early
to set off fireworks for Howell fine
fireworks for how long
oh okay so the person asking is for from
Ireland I guess that's a thing over
there um I would say any time cuz
fireworks for Halloween that's not what
that's not Halloween not to me at any
rate so like ya know that's just just
don't curious about your thoughts on an
lgbtq+ representation in media aimed at
teenagers and kids I think if you're
going to show heterosexual sexuality in
basically anything that's ever been put
out there then there should not be an
issue with representing the the variance
from that and you know with gender
expression I think that's the one people
are getting weirder about right now when
it comes to anything being exposed to
children there's all these cries of
children are confused children are this
and children are that and like my basic
stance is that children are as confused
as you make it for them if children are
confused is because
you're presenting them with things badly
or you already had one thing ingrained
in them and now you're telling them the
opposite and that takes time to process
and that is confusing I do however try
and avoid too many blanket statements
about gender identity when it comes to
pre adults you know whether it be
especially if you're talking preteens or
anything like that just because I feel
that is very much a case by case basis
situation because I have seen and heard
of scenarios that I thought both made
total sense or more okay and others that
I was like that seems I'm not sure I'm
on board with that but when I get
presented with either one of those I
always get the feeling that whoever's
presenting to me very much wants me to
make a blanket statement about oh that's
fine therefore this is always fine or
that seems weird to me therefore this is
all bad and I refuse to do either of
those things so when it comes to gender
identity and and children in terms of
you know raising children and and
allowing for that movement I think being
more flexible than we have historically
as a society is a good thing
I think that's waters that as a society
and as parents we are all navigating and
probably aren't getting right yet so
that's a that's a process alright pop it
on back let's say I'm back up some stuff
okay man are you on Instagram have them
found an official account I am but not
under counsel geeks i'm on instagram
under viewer wild wyl de because i had
to spell wild the most pretentious way i
could possibly think to do it um which
Doctor Who episode hits you more
emotionally than they originally did
given your apparent um I don't think if
there's one that has hit me harder for
that reason specifically well
one that comes to mind actually is
idiots Lantern but not because it hit me
emotionally harder
it made me angrier than I've ever been
and I've hated that I've always hated
that episode but rewatching it now with
the perspective of a parent I hated it
made me so angry that thing so yeah it
has happened but in the negative sense
let me pop on down children are much
more together than people give them
credit for yeah I would agree with that
do you think Gotham is camp oh
absolutely
but Gotham is dark camp which you don't
get along so that's a big part of what I
like about it are you going to do
favorite Dark Crystal characters would
Liz not planning on it I suppose as
possible I'm sorry do you have a guest
for this month's lgbtq+ video not only
do I have a guest I need to wrap this up
relatively soon and get back to editing
that because that was a two-hour
conversation that I have given up trying
to cut down to something shorter and I
think I'm just gonna release it in two
parts
I think some Doctor Who fans missed the
point about the war doctor using
violence saying the doctor has used
files the difference was that it was
usually his last option while for the
war doctor it was the only option yeah
it's all it is always word to me when
like he tends to come up when I talk
about hell-bent and the doctor shooting
somebody people like boy he's he's done
stuff like that before I'm like there
was a massive difference between the
doctor the fifth doctor shooting Omega
because if he didn't the universe
wouldn't would be destroyed and the 12th
doctor shooting someone who was simply
standing in his way and was not an
immediate threat to anybody other than
the doctors own really bad idea that he
was trying to do so like there's a
massive difference between those who's a
youtuber you feel gets way too much crap
I don't know because I really go out of
my way to avoid finding out about
YouTube drama so I don't know how much
crap a lot of the youtubers i watch to
follow are getting or even the ones who
I don't like are getting because I
really really try and stay out of that
are you going to do a review on the raka
man movie probably not but spoiler it is
very likely to show up on my top 10
movies of the year when when we get
there so I think having a Joker movie
runs the risk of demystifying the
character which is a big part of him I'm
not worried about that because it's
completely out of continuity so I don't
think you can claim that it's
demystifying a character when it's only
this one interpretation it's not like
Andy heat we're gonna keep following him
like well no it's just the one time
see I object to giving the Joker in the
comics like in continuity a definitive
origin and background because yes
I agree but for a one-off self-contained
movie whatever I don't think of that as
damaging because nobody's implying that
that is now the canon that everyone
should assume is the case for every
other version of the Joker
see have you seen Gavin and Stacey and
will you carry on with the war master
Big Finish series I saw a little bit of
Gavin and Stacey I kind of liked it but
not enough to stick with it I think I'm
done I can't remember how many of us
ODEs I did maybe three or four however
many were on a disk cuz I watch it way
back when
didn't get Netflix to streaming got it
through the discs so however many
episodes were on the first disc um
didn't stick with it after that it was
okay just wasn't quite for me so you
know it happens hold on I lost where I
was okay here we go oh no I went back
too far sorry I'm just trying to find my
place again how much of Neil Gaiman have
you read current favorite author I read
a bit there's a fair amount of his stuff
that I saw the read but I've read I mean
a red Sandman I've read some of his
other comic work I've read American Gods
ever at a non-si boys I've read
Neverwhere which my favorite thing that
he's written I've read Stardust's I
think that's it there's a fair amount
that I haven't read though and he is
quite good I I do enjoy his work have
you ever had an out-of-body experience
no I mean not waking like I'm I'll have
stuff like that happen in dreams but I
wouldn't count that so no I haven't I
can listen to your rambles for two hours
hahaha ah but your videos on one of the
back
around during work time oh thank you
actually met Neil Gaiman was totally
worth it yeah okay Carolyn we are now
all official officially jealous cuz that
is awesome he seems like such a cool guy
you know it's serious when he takes his
glasses off oh and I met and I didn't I
didn't answer the will I carry on with
the war Master Big Finish series um
eventually I might I mean the the Big
Finish sets aren't cheap even going
strictly digital um so and then it's a
question of time like I absolutely want
to cuz I really liked series one of the
war master I just don't know when what
what anger do you about the idiots
Lantern okay what angered me on the
rewatch cuz I'd forgotten cuz I again I
never liked that episode what angered me
is the very end of it when the father
the abusive shouting horrible father
is effectively kicked out of the house
it takes his bag he's leaving and Rose
says to his son go to him you have to
he's your dad Anna
screw you Rose Tyler I know you've got
daddy issues I get why she would be the
one to say that but f you know and F
that episode for framing it like that
was good advice that you go to the
person who was destroying your home
actively this abusive factor in your
life that just barely exited yeah go up
and maintain ties with that I'm not
saying that there was no way to ever
have that father be redeemed but not
literally seconds out of her after he's
out of the house let him stew let him
live with some consequences to his damn
actions for once telling this kid to go
back to his abusive day Oh Oh God that
pissed me off
and one live stream you said if you
could you want to do better locations
personally please don't do that for any
more than 1 oz because I think the
current wants to iconic I mean what I
meant by that is there are some things
that I have planned that I want to I
want to do things that don't work in
this space so it's not as when I say
other locations I don't mean like I'm
gonna change my standard shootings no I
just mean there are certain things that
I want to do that would that either
wouldn't work in the space I usually use
for shooting or would work much better
in a slightly different setting and
that's what I meant by that I don't mean
a permanent relocation sorry if I missed
it but our Big Finish reviews moving to
the podcast for the classic who Big
Finish reviews are kind of on hiatus
right now um cuz I just I just don't
have the time for them I say that I was
actually commissioned to do a Big Finish
review and that next month I think so
like it'll still come up every now and
then but like it's it's kind of off the
docket for the time being I think he'll
Ben was the doctor tired of losing
especially because his companions don't
usually end well again I'm not saying
there was no justification for it I'm
just saying I hate it if you could had
one for stability what would you have oh
the mind drink always
I think it's cannon that not even the
Joker knows his true backstory I don't
know if that is especially now cuz
they've done the whole three Joker's
things which I don't even know if that's
finished playing out
and I don't get and I don't did yeah I
would guess Rose telling the boy to go
with his abusive father there's a reason
narrative Lee why it works but if I
explain I think a little geeks will get
angry
yeah I kind of well you're not wrong not
at you specifically just at like why
does society think that people have
sexual orientations and identity with
gender identities because they see other
people like that monkey-see monkey-do 2
does not work like that I mean here's
the thing to a certain extent it
actually does happen but only insofar as
I do think that if people who have have
lived a completely sister normative
heteronormative life get exposed to the
possibilities of just that people can be
bisexual homosexual transgender
non-binary what-have-you
I do think that does open up the
possibility of them to think about that
in a way they had never before and but
it's not an imitation thing it's not oh
I saw that person was trans I'm trans
now I just mean that like what can
happen is that people can see something
that suddenly speaks to a part of
themselves that they didn't have words
for before and what that can look like
to outsiders who object to people not
being cisgender and heterosexual how
that can look to them is oh that person
was perfectly normal until they saw all
this queerness
and that screwed them up like no that
allowed them to realize and find words
for something about themselves that they
already knew was off but it can look
like from the outside looking in
like they just saw and imitated so I get
why some people say oh I mean some
people say it's a it's a complete
smokescreen and you know it's bad faith
argument but I get why some people come
to that conclusion incorrectly not
specifically trying to you know push a
negative against that but still end up
coming to that conclusion because if you
don't know enough about the situation
there's a lot of ways to misinterpret
stuff can hear how bad
wanna drop an f-bomb during the eighties
Lantern Randy yeah could you tell I just
want to hear gram and Jodi say no flow
Kono's so flow mama ever seen the French
movie intouchables I have not don't know
that one do you think slither and
Ravenclaw's get along well goodness I
hope so my partner's a ravenclaw
it's 3 a.m. where I live I'm gonna get
some sleep now that's a good idea and
actually I should wrap this up soon I'm
just gonna try and see if I can grab any
of the last few questions here oh
goodness
they've been piling up um let's see if
you ever have the time Yeah right
hearing about your hectic schedule yeah
you should read Doctor Who combat MAGIX
is a 13 story with focus on Y as
internal thoughts I would much prefer
that we got more inside and Yaz on the
show just sayin
burn in hell spider-man one more day see
I've never actually read that I'm well
aware of one more day I know it's
reputation and why people have issues
with it I haven't actually read it so
you know give me your dislike of TV
Sixth Doctor how much would you be
willing to watch trial of a Time Lord
ass it's Terry's long story I mean I'm
gonna have to eventually it's it's on
the to-do list I mean eventually I hope
to catch up on all of classic ooh okay
my sweetie darlings
my birthday Prosecco glass is empty
thank you for the birthday wishes love
you all thanks for being you Thank You
Donna for sharing some of your birthday
time with us honestly it wouldn't be
surprised if Ed Haim will be a future
showrunner especially if his series 12
story is good they will see I I don't
like to speculate about future show
runners or future doctors or anything
like that because I want to try and
enjoy you know what we have as best as I
can while we have it
[Music]
did you hear that they them was added by
Marian Webster as an official pronoun I
did not cool who would win in a fight
between Jack Robertson and head Henry
van Statten trying to I know who Henry
van Statten is I if I know who Jack
Robertson is I am grana blank
I like the idiot slander him because it
was the only DVD I I had had to rewatch
it over and over and over again well
yeah no I mean that happens that's
basically fandom bye-bye Stockholm
Syndrome that's a thing you're awesome
by the way I hope you have a brilliant
week month etc you appreciate Thank You
Jay I appreciate you too appreciate all
you folks what's your favorite type of
cheese cheddar aged preferably final
thoughts before you wrap up keep doing
what you're doing love it thank you very
much
and yes I should definitely wrap up so
Oh inside tip in case you folks don't
already do it best way to have apple
cider warmed with a cinnamon stick Oh
Thank You Carolyn flattered Jack
Robertson is the oh I guess I take Henry
van Statten between the two of those
yeah anyways so hope everyone had a good
night this was a this was an instructor
one like I've been o slightly
overwhelmed last couple weeks um so
maybe we'll have a theme next week if I
can start pulling it together again but
in any case folks thanks so much for
tuning in thank you for your support
your comments likes shares everything
that folks do even if all you do is
watch I'm still grateful for you if you
do anything more than that I'm
absolutely grateful for that I mean it's
just nice to have you folks to talk to
once a week I mean in addition to all
the videos I put up but you know just I
always like this so thank you all for
tuning in and I just want you all to
remember that you are beautiful you are
valid you are loved you are the counsel
I'm just running the meetings
have a good night